it is absolutely absolutely
Paramount
that every writer get to that space
should someone be fearful with building
their entertainment career or at least
cautious
um
yeah I guess so but you know mostly be
Fearless because what I mean by that is
um is that
um
their
there are so many
forces
that want to strip you of your voice as
a writer
um and to make you compromise that voice
and and to
um
to make undermine that voice and confuse
you into thinking that you should
undermine your voice
and that's ridiculous that's absolutely
ridiculous
um
the the the the greatest the greatest
writers
um in screenwriting
we
we know who they are
simply because
not only when we read the scripts you
know their voice is um is apparent and
and and Rises to the surface but when we
we see the the finished products it's
apparent I mean it's like how would you
how do you how do you separate you know
I mean you know the sound of Tarantino
you know
it's like you know I mean it's like you
know you know the sound of Diablo Cody
you know you you know the sound of of
Spike Lee I mean these people have
sounds
you know
that's your voice and if you're not
working
um you know you if you're not you know
sharpening your quiver to towards that
to towards that direction
then you're not going to ever sort of
stand out from the crowd because that's
what ultimately is the goal that's what
makes you you know if we're going back
to our Michael Clayton analogy that
makes you the the the commodity that
cannot be
um
um avoided that that people have to come
to in the end it's going well we need
him to do this you know we need we need
to call we need to call up
um um um um um
um oh I'm forgetting her name it's a
Phoebe Waller
um Bridge we need to call her to punch
up a script you know because we need
that voice
we need that voice and and and and and
and all you need to do is say her name
and you know what her voice means
to that to that project
it is it is absolutely absolutely
Paramount
that every writer get to that space
because then you know people you know
agents producers Executives they're
they're they get bombarded with crap
you know they get
bombarded with a lot of the same of this
or a lot of you know like this or you
know or or people people that sound like
saying back
people that sound like this you know
people like you know that's you know
that that want to be David peoples
people that you know
and
um
and they don't really want that
they want you
they want to know who you are
you know they want something that's so
unique
and um that that they can go oh well you
know nobody else has that so this is
this is the One-Stop shop where you can
go to it's a you only can go to that
store to get that
that's it you said I think writing
screenplays specifically is a love for
the art storytelling
yeah yeah and that uh sort of dovetails
to what I was discussing before
um a little bit with um mining
um the written word but um
um yeah it's when I'm but also just to
elaborate on that it it's really the
classic
um
it's the classic example of
um having that um that command of
telling a story around a campfire
and
um to take people through a journey that
um that keeps them
um entertained but also leaves them with
um
with um with something
something that sort of delights them in
a special way
that is The Art of Storytelling that is
the um
the thing that has occurred time and
memorium since you know the cavemen were
drawing on drawing on the the the sides
of uh of the caves so it's the it's
that's that's what I'm speaking of I'm
speaking to
and that's what you do
um with um with the screenplays the
first is this is the first
um
brick in in building that wall
um the wall where it will be projected
eventually it's
um you know the theater is the big
um it's the big cave that we all we all
um huddle inside
I like that
so it's not just the love of the final
product which is seeing these characters
come to life and getting an audience
reaction to will they laugh at this part
will they gasp at this part but also
just the the real love for crafting it
and and
ruminating over this word or should this
character enter here or there well I
think that
um all filmmakers and what I mean by all
filmmakers is that all
um all Crafts People in the art of
filmmaking from the writer to um to the
production designer to the actor to the
director
um to hopefully the producers uh
um have a a passion for telling stories
and that's where that's where everyone
collaborates that's where everyone comes
together
because they go how can we tell this
story in the best possible way because
everyone's excited about that Prospect
and that notion it's actually
um a larger than it's larger than any
one one person's
um aspect on on the production is no one
is the sole Avatar of that of that
objective you know it's like oh how can
we tell this this great story we're all
excited about you know
how can we succeed at that